and the Oscar goes to Matthew
[Applause]
mccon I had so much with the script that
was written I remember saying I boy that
the scene just kind of comes off the
page it's bleeding off the
page news FL for y'all ain't nothing out
there can kill R woodu in 30
days and then I went to see his family
his family opened up their house to me
they had every scrapbook out and then
they gave me his diary that was
definitely my secret weapon that's when
I got Ron's monologue who's the guy when
he's sitting home alone at night who's
that guy that's when I really felt like
I had the ammunition or the at least the
life force but beyond who he
was just need to slow it down a little
bit just get me down and Catch My Breath
will ain't ready to crawl on a corner
huh Matthew brings an incredible
commitment to the character of Ron I
think he raised the bar and I think he
did that by his commitment to incredible
weight loss and character and his focus
and his determination to do something
great to do something better
then it was a challenge in that we were
shooting so much daily we had 25 days to
make the movie you didn't have time to
say so what is this about what what are
we doing today and what it really mean
time was so precious you couldn't be so
considered about anything besides what
was happening in the scene part of what
everyone is drawn to in Matthew is that
he is someone who is so himself all the
time and Ron Woodruff is himself nice
restaurant beautiful woman it's where I
feel like a human again when we do our
job the best people see themselves in us
in a performance we see ourselves in a
performance and vice versa part of what
my father ingrained in US is my dad's
always rooted for the underdog and
that's one of the great things on a very
human level of who Aon woodriff was a
great Underdog who thrived and survived
in a time when when it was really tough
too to my father who I know he's up
there right now with a big pot of Gumbo
he's got a lemon mering pie over there
he's probably in his underwear and he's
got a cold can of Miller Light and he's
dancing right
[Music]
now